you sure you've not been going gym i'm
not gonna like your trap
we're never usually this close your trap
is feeling a bit
thick i'm not gonna lie your posterior
chain
this sirloin thing here this phillips
thing here down the back
dense is it here even on that mexican
supplement
right ladies and gents what's good
people what's going on
um we're here again so this is going to
be our last episode
in this new temporary studio
so let's have some more fun love love
love love love hope you're well
um hope you're weak it's monday today so
i hope your week
proves to be fruitful fam that's
actually the word i was looking for okay
i was going to say flourishing or
something like that i was looking for a
fruitful
hope the week is fruitful for you man i
hope you guys have been uh loving and
laughing with us
yeah as always guys jump on the patreon
jump on the merch the links are in the
description
uh please support the show um have some
fun with us over on the patreon
get involved um like comment subscribe
man
brush your fingers over the like comment
subscribe hit the notifications
it actually does a lot for us it does um
i just want i think i owe you guys an
apology man
i've always been really mean to people
who don't sign up to patreon straight
away
okay but i really i love them really but
i'm just
i just i just want to be rich bro
but we really do appreciate literally
regardless if you're on patreon
if you're on youtube if you're on
spotify if you're an apple podcast if
you're paying
any attention to us whatsoever we
appreciate it we appreciate you dude
because we don't deserve it for sure
yeah for sure we don't deserve it
whatsoever
thank you so
oh much with this [ __ ] bro sorry guys
um yeah we don't deserve it whatsoever
so
um
you don't know it take over yeah man
like jimmy's saying we don't we don't
deserve it but
we appreciate all the love as always
every single time man we can week out
you guys support us and
yeah man we're always going to be
eternally grateful it's it's crazy to
think that we've created and cultivated
such a
huge community you know you guys dm must
reach out to us comments
instagram twitter and yeah man we love
you guys so we do we do we always love
to give back hence the merchandise and
things like that you know
like so you know patreon jump on that as
per
three pound a month run us the p gang
gang as per um like comment subscribe as
we said
and we're going to get into food has fun
fact
um so today jimmy i'm recently talking
about a lot of people
that i've got another guy so in 2005 a
south african man called marius ells
adopted a baby hippo after rescuing it
from a river
six years later aft sorry
baby hippo after rescue from a river six
years later after years of bonding
between the two
the hippo dragged him into the same
river and ate him
of course it did family
family of course it did what possesses
anyone to adopt something that's not
meant to be adopted oh they're
wild beasts for a reason bro they've got
one of the
strongest draws i think all the
strongest like tensile strength yeah
whatever it's called like the grip
the bite isn't
i couldn't imagine that stabbing they're
violent
they're violent i've seen them break off
watermelons like
that bro do you think it's mad that
these men know
who and who can't breathe underwater
wow you're coming down with me because i
can i'll be all right
i've never deep that i've never
they drowned man do you know what that
just reminded me of not because of that
specific thing
but because of me saying i've never deep
that do you remember when
we had the question of would you [ __ ]
your
mom in your skull's body the mind thing
the mind switched to yeah
i was reading through the comments
because i was on tick tock i was looking
like you said you love me to comment
sometimes i looked on tik tok and i was
scrolling through the comments
and one of the comments said even if you
[ __ ]
your girl with your mom's brain your mum
will always remember
and i was like yuck
yuck because i that never dawned on me
oh right once there was once they
switched back yeah your mum would
always your mom will always know what
you feel like
yeah that's disgusting and i was like oh
my
god mind blown because i completely
forgot about that because i only ever
think or thought about
it in the act at that moment yeah yeah
yeah after the
the repercussions afterwards you might
just kill yourself not worthy just kill
yourself let them wood
i see one guy comment like bro i'm
keeping them as they are yeah yeah
no one's switching it's almost [ __ ]
nice
um oh my god but yeah bro
man adopted a hippo it's a gang six
years later the hippo said enough is
enough
fam you're boring me bro i don't want to
hear your story shut up
marius you [ __ ] up yeah come in this
water
bro imagine what the fear he must have
felt when it was dragging him in
he must have thought he was play play
bro he must have been thinking you can't
be
[ __ ] serious bro i've nurtured you i
saved your
life you're doing this to me
bro to me he must have felt like denzel
washington training
do this to me oh my days he would have
been
facts and there was no one around just
him in the ocean
screamed bro molten a way to go
ah man yeah long story short don't take
wild animals and adopt them just like
leave them be they're not meant to be on
in yards dude
hippo [ __ ] man that's it that's it if
you adopt a tiger and
keep it for 10 15 20 years or whatever
it's going to eat you one day bro
they don't care i don't give a [ __ ]
that's like chimps bro have you heard
about what chimps do
young people adopt chimps and stuff like
that oh do you know how strong
chimps are
so strong okay like um
something like i heard like a gorilla
for example that's not a chimp but
i think a gorilla can something this is
the statistics or something like it can
probably like deadlift or carry like 4
000 pounds yeah i've seen that before
yeah he said gorilla deadlift
deadlift
[Music]
it's an audacious amount it can't be
kilos do you know how strong that is
it's an audacious amount that's
ridiculous man will say
oh thanks yank
pop your arm out your socks just you
know that when you give someone a
handshake that fake thing where you
got that yeah yeah oh my days he would
destroy yours
it'd be so easy so quick seamless
you wouldn't feel the pain because it'd
be that quick you'd be done for
fam i'm all right that couldn't be me
yeah no one's killing these animals bro
and these lot want to adopt them and put
them in nappies and [ __ ] keep keep them
where they're meant to be bro
i don't say you deserve it but it's it's
it's mental why would you even want to
do that
i don't know man i'm pretty sure i've
heard a story about um a woman who was
raising a chimp in the chimp
ate her [ __ ] face off really oh
that why does that ring a bell unless
maybe you told me
i don't think i've told you but maybe i
did they eat in the face of kind of
rings about i don't know why oh i don't
know her
[ __ ] face off that's that's cruel
man raised you know big man don't raise
me in it
don't raise me if you can't hang don't
raise me bro
basically if you ain't got these
knuckles literally if you can't hang
don't race me
bro you thought it was a game
frogs now bro you're raising a wild
animal if you can't hang
then let me be free let me be free
because i'm finna swing oh [ __ ] you up
bro how much i can't how can i respect
you
you're a feeble old woman brother and
you wipe my ass that's what you do
i [ __ ] and you clean it up and you're
not telling me what to do
you're saying i can't have cookies big
man your face is your face your
face is snatched off i'll be fine
without you oh that's hilarious
yeah man i don't know why people do [ __ ]
like that oh my god neither do i
even let nature be nature man 100 100 of
you
but yeah anyway um would you rather oh
yeah
oh actually no i have uh before i have
like a topic i want to talk about
yes it's never going to be real quick it
never is real quick i love it anyway
so i've thought about this forever and
like
i had the perfect example even though
it's not a real life scenario but it's
just
it just goes to show first of all what
people think they're
entitled to and secondly just how
everything is all make believing fake
so have you watched superstore no you
should for starters
i've heard it's jokes been binging it
it's wonderful i've been i've
been bingeing modern family currently
that's why um
you know why i like superstars cause
superstars is the next binge of since i
left
since i finished the office yeah that's
my superstar's the next one
i actually prefer binge i don't prefer
the show i prefer
bingeing superstar because the office is
so funny
it's a bit intense sometimes do you ever
find that i know what you mean i know
what you mean like it's an easy watch
yeah yeah
some of it's so funny just like i don't
really want a belly laugh right now i
just want to watch something
yeah yeah the family is nice because
something you don't have to concentrate
yeah in a nutshell let it happen
yeah yeah yeah office you kind of have
with like obviously like jim's pranks
and all this stuff and dwight and like
michael
you really have to follow the story of
the office to see what's going on you
can't just like breezily watch it
with superstar bro oh bro it
feels like a massage for your brain you
can really just turn off and enjoy the
show
okay it's so nice okay i've been
watching it non-stop anyway
spoiler alert um so there's a
lady in there and like one of the main
characters she
makes [ __ ] all money as just like a
normal employee
she then gets promoted to the general
manager she makes 100k a year
okay she makes 100k a year so she's been
she's gone from making minimum wage
to 100 grand a year guys and i thought
hello
how are life's changed now yeah yeah
but there's no way in hell if she ever
loses this job
she's going back to where she was of
course not of course not she's getting
another job
yeah either for more money or at least
the same round about the same ballpark
yeah so
once but really nothing has changed
about her whatsoever
she's got the exact same skill set she
had when because she didn't really have
to learn much new when she became
manager okay she's got the same skill
set she had
as manager as she did as like a floor
walker um
except she makes 100k now and now 100k
is her baseline
and she thinks she deserves 100k and if
someone will offer her
60 should be offended but do you know
what i'm worth
and i've actually seen that with people
um that i know
okay over the last few years and they
get a job
where they make a bit of money and
that's just what they're worth now
okay and on one side you're like mate
fair play chase the bag
get as much out of anyone as you can
possibly get like you deserve the world
and on the other hand i'm a bit like you
also don't deserve
[ __ ] because yesterday you were making
this much and you were fine with it
now you managed to somehow get yourself
a job that pays more
and all of a sudden this is what you
deserve forever now
i'm never going to accept anything less
than this now yeah and you're like
this is all just made up clearly this is
all just made up
because like i don't know like i've
for example like sales is a big one as
well like in sales you can go from a job
in sales that's paying you
like 18k a year you're still doing
hardcore like bro
some of the hard most hardcore sales
people work the shittiest jobs for the
shittest money
like door-to-door salesman yeah telecom
sales people stuff like that bro these
guys are
grinders and they make [ __ ] cool
money bro
they daughtered off for a month i
remember oh no i remember you did as
well
not even a month probably like a week
and a half yeah you didn't do it for a
moment you said my
differently i didn't even know i don't
know who
they make [ __ ] all money so you take all
that sales experience
you're going to [ __ ] indeed.com or
some [ __ ] and you see a job there paying
you 45.
and you what you were your experience
you've got everything that they're
looking for
and you can go in there and start making
serious commission because you've got
all this skill set you've been grinding
in the trenches for years
so you go over there all of a sudden you
make a 45 now
and nothing has changed you're no better
than the person that you left behind at
the last place okay so you've not gained
anything new
no man you're just getting the money
yeah because that's how i said sales
because sales is just [ __ ] sales fair
enough it's the same
[ __ ] job because your product is
different i hear you i hear you now okay
sales is just sales it's all the same
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay okay
and it's like um it's
exactly the same as other things as well
like if you for example like obviously
you're a restaurant manager yeah
you make x amount but that's probably
got more to do
with your bottom line will eventually in
the in the broad scale of things will
have more to do
with the success of that restaurant than
your skills as a restaurant
if you you could work for a like a
family-owned italian
i'd be making 15 grand a year because
that's all they can afford yeah then you
move up to the big boys yeah
and you're making 40 50. but like the
job as a manager
was potentially harder at the last place
yeah you got less support you got less
people
you had to really really run that [ __ ]
the skills that you had to use in
in this last place were probably way
more than you'd have to use the big boys
the big boys can afford to pay you more
so they do but all of a sudden now that
you make this much
you even you work less but this is what
you deserve now mm-hmm
this is the money you deserve and
everything from there needs to be up up
up up up up up up up
up and i just feel like sometimes people
move into that position
and then they think they actually are
worth way more than they are
and i want to be like kevin samuels i'm
like you deserve nothing bro
what what show me your new skills yeah
yeah what's different from two years
yeah since when you
say from when you moved up from two
grand a month to four grand a month yeah
and now you want five
what what new skills have you brought to
the table from when you went on two
because i can't see [ __ ] all new all i
see is this ego comes
that's all i see yeah is this ego bro
show me the skills yeah yeah yeah yeah i
hear that
i hear that what made you think about
that in the superstar mainly because
yeah i've seen it in my own life
okay and i think about like i just hate
the entitlement that i hear people's
mouth sometimes yeah
and then i watched it on a superstore
and when you just added
she's got chest now she's the manager
she walks around like this
is it is it the american foreigners are
peeled back
she's walking with chest and she keeps
saying about like oh well you know i
make more money now i make more money
now she says it all the time
and you're just like big man you could
get sacked tomorrow but even if you get
sacked tomorrow you're gonna be looking
for more manager jobs yeah yeah yeah
yeah because you think you're there
you think you're there now i think
you've got the skill set yeah yeah yeah
yeah the same thing [ __ ] changed
and i see that a lot man and it pisses
me off it was more of a rant than
anything else but yeah i could tell
yeah it just brought it annoys me but at
the same time like i said before it's
like
yeah why shouldn't you change chase your
best
i think there's a difference between
chasing what you want and believing you
deserve [ __ ] that you don't
no one really deserves anything
i'm certain that the hardest workers in
the world get paid the least
of course without a shadow of a doubt
well i've worked some [ __ ] horrific
jobs horrific jobs yeah yeah yeah
bless you this is a nightmare it's a
living life
um yeah i've got some horrific jobs bro
like working nights loading heavy ass
boxes into lawrence yeah i remember
all night bro i remember when the only
people around me are racist polish
people
i deserved 500 000
pounds a year for that job bro it was a
living nightmare every second of it was
hell yeah
and then my most high in paying jobs i
just remember chilling on my ass bro
and i [ __ ] around for 90 of the day
[Music]
i know what you mean bro and then i call
a few people and i'm like yeah yeah you
want this and they're like yeah all
right
and i'm like yeah going pay me more bro
yeah i'm questioning it i'm sick
and you're just like what the [ __ ] is
going on it's
um it's an upside down pyramid man it
makes no sense but it's just yeah it is
it's true it is how the world is it
doesn't make any sense
doesn't make any sense at all but yeah
anyway uh i did have a woodworker
actually yeah i'm sorry i was like no
don't be sorry about it was a good food
for thought kind of thing i liked it
it's actually interesting would you
rather
go back to the 10 year old self
with all the knowledge that you know
today
or someone just give you 20 mil right
now
okay
um
i think the 20mm will entice me
straightaway because
that's that's instant gratification
exactly exactly money money now exactly
but i love the idea of going back with
what i know now
you can change i can church entire game
everything
you can so that's very intriguing as
well
i don't know whether the thing is i also
don't know whether
i would i don't know i also don't know
whether i would
be in the position i am today if i was
to go back and change everything
knowing why i still know now because
obviously i'm not obviously i'm a firm
believer of everything happens for a
reason
and the reason why we're here today is
because we kind of we crossed paths and
we got here to where we are this is our
journey now you know
and i feel like if i went back
knowing the knowledge i have now i'd
mess it up somehow
i'd mess up the the timeline i know what
you mean
you know you wouldn't be able to it's
impossible to
obviously i'm not trying to recreate the
last whatever 20 years
but even though i'll try and make my
decisions better fork in the road i'll
probably choose right instead of left
like i did left instead of right last
time
i probably i might not be here that's
what i'm saying like 20 years time yeah
like
you'd want to go back and get rid of all
the
negativity yeah with that but whilst
keeping all the positives
yeah but whilst getting rid of that
negativity whilst you were in that
situation like the perfect example for
me was that i used to be always
i think i've said it i might have said
on here before but i used to be so
angry for so long that my mum made me
take a levels instead of
go to college and do um diploma or
whatever i think
you mentioned it before i think you
mentioned it before a basketball story
yeah yeah yeah yeah and like she made me
take a levels which i hated
all i wanted to do was sport she
wouldn't let me do it um and i wanted to
go to
college to do sport yeah where all my
friends went she wouldn't let me
yeah she said all you need to have
broader options and all this stuff so
she may be taking their levels
i flunked my a levels and commentary was
like the only uni that would have me
for a sport course with the a levels
that i got whereas all my other boys
who did weren't even as smart as me in
that topic yeah
did very well yeah and they got offers
for like loughborough
birmingham this and that and i'm like
this is [ __ ] yeah yeah you know he's
always thinking [ __ ] if i could just go
back in black mom no definitely i'm
going to close like i don't care what
you say this is what i'm doing
then i could have been a sick uni i
could have done that but then now
i wouldn't have met you i would have met
any of our friends i wouldn't
i would not be doing this podcast right
now i would not be in that position
different role
i'll be working a [ __ ] job bro you might
be making pee
i've probably been making racks yeah
yeah um i'd probably be the [ __ ]
physio for manual some [ __ ]
i don't know the world would have been
my own yeah
i'll be having a [ __ ] boring life yeah
this is fun
and i would have spent [ __ ] three
four years at loughborough uni with
pretentious douchebags yeah man
yeah [ __ ] after hearing that
and actually diving into the question
why i picked the 20 mil you picked the
20 million yeah because you're happy
with what you get
yeah i'm i'm more than happy with what i
got i'm not content i'm fulfilled with
what i've got
um it's the drainage been crazy
obviously yes we want more
but the instant gratification of the 20
mil right now knowing that
the journey we've taken we can take this
to a whole nother level
because going back 20 years and trying
to relive and change decisions like you
said we might not be here
because now i know the life we live i
want to do this i'm still going to do
this so the 20 mil now
it will do a lot for us bro now
everything stays the same i can have a
lay in every
day [ __ ] day we will be releasing
episodes left
oh bro i can eat sushi till i [ __ ]
myself bro
every day oh god the quality will be ah
bro the production will be sky high they
just be laughing
laughing bro yeah man oh you'll never be
hungry again again
again oh yeah bro yeah yeah
yeah 20 mil that sounds that sounds
fantastic that's healthy yeah man run
the 20 bill please
casually casual or even just
i've been doing scratch cards your boys
picked himself up a little happy hap
your voice picked up you know when i
[ __ ] you know when i knew it was toxic
and i [ __ ] up what
i won 10 pounds on a scratch card the
other day i was gasps
five scratch cards please one nothing
on those five squares first one nothing
that's the same with the lottery though
because i play a lot you like
maybe every other week there are some
months i play every week
um and i think the most i'd won was in
the first lockdown i won nearly seven
bills
and then i remembered anything yeah i
won 97 bills in the first lockdown
and then i've i started to win like 20
pound like i want 100
here or you want like an extra ticket
but you think this week is going to be
the week you pick the numbers
like boom i can't wait i'm like this
week's gonna be it's like [ __ ] man
it's just it's just not gonna happen bro
the lorry's never gonna happen
but i keep playing i just have that
feeling yeah but that's the same with me
in my scratch cards
bro yeah i went to shop the other day
bought my scratch cards i said ask for
three right yeah
she got me two yeah and then i was like
i
couldn't i was already out of the shop
when i realized you'd have to give me
two
yeah i really could not be bothered to
be back i'm like sorry i asked for free
and then get another one i was like [ __ ]
it man i'll just stick with two yeah i
guess the scratch card for god's sake
bro and i didn't win nothing on either
of them and i remember thinking
that third one was 250k i know for a
fact
i know for a fact that the third one
that she didn't give me was 250 grams
bro that will burn you you can't think
about that bro
yeah your boy's got himself a little
happy have happy hab
it's a it's bad it's a bad habit you
have that's jokes
happy habit i like ah [ __ ] but yeah it's
it's not good man but that's a lot of it
i feel like i'm closer to winning with
the scratch cards
of course because it looks a lot more
realistic yeah it seems a lot i feel
like a lot i'll just i just
the odds for me and the lottery just yes
it's too far-fetched yeah yeah
sometimes i play the euro if i'm feeling
audacious because that's
not obviously it's more expensive and
the odds are a lot higher yeah yeah yeah
um oh sorry a lot less rather but it's
it's crazy it's crazy because after
winning that first one i'm thinking i
can win more
bro i'm gonna win more for sure i can
win seven bills is a lot bro i was
guessed oh i [ __ ] bet if i if how did
you get it how did they give it to you
i was online online yeah i didn't know
you didn't even play online yeah
that's a good idea straight in my
account that's a good thing
i was one number away because for some
reason they were doing like a rollover
thing i was meant to win a hundred and
something pounds
but it didn't roll over double down
rollover and i won 670. if i'd gotten
one more number which was in another
line
vexed about out of one i think two and a
half k
you couldn't tell them i've just won two
and a half candle lottery
the funny thing is i remember i woke up
and saw it because i think i went to
piss
then i just landed you looked on my
phone and i looked at the email and said
you have good great news
because you get that email great news
you have one but i'm always thinking two
pound one pound ten people whatever you
know this
no never had that email i've had it bare
times never happened
but i'll take that right now i've never
had anything wait sorry
just before you carry on your story do
you use the same numbers every time when
you mix no
you mix it up every time you never use
the same numbers really yeah
i know people i know it's a thing that
people should i always mix up
fair play do you do that lucky dip or do
you actually pick the numbers
because i obviously can pick rose in i
pick like five rows at the time i do it
yeah three to five rows
i do half or some lucky dip some i
picked myself you're a veteran bro oh i
just put that
up yeah i can tell you're fluent you're
speaking fluid like it's your language
i've been in the trenches man i'm
telling you i've been scooping up these
ten pounds these five pounds
now you're okay you're a gambler
ah i thought it was about my little
screechy scratch
little chicken scratch you're out
like you're doing the triple flip flop
double rollover
nah i can't remember what i was saying
now um
what was what was the method to this
madness what was i talking about um
so one a rolled over or if i won the
forgot the fourth number i wanted one
two
one two and a half k i would have i said
if i would have built you that you lost
your mind
what the context was yeah
i would love to win the lorry winning
the lottery bro
banging yard guys in the comments below
what would you do if you won the lottery
let us know yeah be realistic as well
obviously
you have you've now got like 20 million
your account so anything's realistic but
what's the first thing you do what's the
first thing you do to underline bro
first thing i do if i'm winning the
lottery is i'm eat
maybe because i'm really hungry right
now all i can think about is i want to
eat something
crazy yeah i'm starving right now bro
i'll go to a spot i don't even know
where or when but i go to a spot and
i just want oh dim sum yeah order it all
give me all of that [ __ ] i'd order it
all uh
i want all the sauces bro i want to try
everything yeah there's one
thing oh yeah yeah i love food i'm
thinking i'm having chinese tonight it's
sunday
i'm having chinese tonight
tonight bro we're having chinese tonight
nah i want chinese tonight bro
i better make it home in time i think
they lock off at 11.
i'll get that around 10. you can order
it order it like before your last stop
and then by the time you get there but i
want it now you said that one how many
chinese tonight
all right gang gang gang gang because
there's chinese cause i told you i'm
sleeping at my mom's tonight right
the chinese near my mom's
it doesn't make sense bro these men are
using
msg for sure they must bro because
you're picking
oh my god i banged their food the rice
is so
fluffy oh it don't make sense the
the crispy shredded beef bro with chili
sauce oh i can't imagine get the
[ __ ] out of here man when last time i
was in london i went to my place i was
obviously you know i was chilling out
here all the chinese i think this was
last time maybe the time before we were
the chinese they've got these wings bro
i was sucking bone it was like seven or
eight of us we were all like
their wings but i didn't order i think
because i think i bought i had noodles
at his yard
so i tried the wings i was like [ __ ] we
need to get more of these wings things
are banging
um but they were closed so one of my
boys was
cussing me for trying to find the wings
online i was like he was like ha
about 20 minutes later he was finishing
off his wings
for like five minutes this spray was
sucking on the bone bro the cartilage
i was like every minute you've been
cussing me you were you've been sucking
mine for the time
because plugged in [ __ ] it was peak
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's that reminds
me i'm eating chinese
my stomach stomach is
rumbling i'm starving i'm so hungry are
you sure you've not been going gym
i don't know like you're trapped we're
never usually this close
your trap is feeling a bit thick i'm not
gonna lie
your posterior chain this sirloin thing
here
this fillet thing here down the back
dense
is that here even on that mexican
supplement
you've not been telling me what you've
been taking oh that's hilarious
i'm too hungry i'm way too hungry let me
laugh at that
[ __ ] you know all right let's do a
mighty [ __ ] man let's uh let me see
what i got actually
no no no no
[Music]
the thing is i'm happy because i can't
remember it but i was obviously yeah i
really remember it
go go go go go go go guys
buckle your [ __ ] seat belts i'm ready
this one's about to go off i'm ready
right
feel like this is a bit long it is but i
want you guys opinion
am i the [ __ ] so i really want to
paint the picture here i'm going to
read it really slow and like really
delve into it i want everyone to get
what the [ __ ] this is get comfortable
get comes when i read this my jaw hit
the floor
get comfortable guys embrace it all
right here why the [ __ ]
so we're seeing a guy on and off for a
year yeah he was a bit of a [ __ ]
yeah there was a big age gap i'm 22 and
he's 36. he's slinging digging wow
but when i tell you i was attracted to
this man
it is not a joke i wanted to
suck him off she put the caps suck him
off
bro that's what we're talking about that
would have turned any man on
of course a young 20 song for a 30
sighting he ain't been hard like that
anymore no
bro but yeah continue in the beginning
it was all good yeah things started to
change
he has a short fuse and we would argue
over the tiniest things
then he started borrowing money from him
from me sorry
no man he told me a day i could get the
money back
big man she's 22.
and you're borrowing money context guys
get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] together brother bro
together
get out of your [ __ ] make sure it's
together morty
right then he started borrowing money
from me he told me a day i could get the
money back
and that day came and went oh
still didn't pay me but he but we
decided on another date and it was all
calm
i knew he was going through a hard time
as he was providing for family back home
due to someone passing he's definitely
he's from the caribbean or from jamaica
or [ __ ]
caribbean jamaica caribbean or africa
send the money back home
that's a family thing fam come on
his whole attitude changed you could
just tell he was going through it
we would just chill drink a little smoke
a little
[ __ ] a lot and i think it was stress
relief for him
i was just about
[Music]
he met my family ages ago because he
came to a family barbecue and everything
was cool
a few weeks ago behind my back my mom
and sister took it upon themselves to
decide this man was using for me for
money
and turned up at his work and caused a
scene
without saying a word to me that's a
ruckus
i was baffled he was blowing up my phone
going crazy
within reason of course of course and i
was just shook
i didn't know what was going on or what
to do
it ended up with him pushing my sister
over because she tried to grab him it's
his man's place of work you know
no firm you're trying to grab me up no
firm
i'm thinking about me you're in it
no i'm there me the mom and the sister
were there we're live
so bear in mind this guy is wham
six three and just strong she's getting
thrown about of course she is fine right
my sister's five five and
he just grabbed it by the throat and
slung her on the floor
jesus christ long story short we ended
up blocking each other on everything the
police got involved
as he said he was going to press charges
for harassment but
he was gonna pressure he was gonna press
charges for harassment but changed his
mind when he saw the cctv
he looked incriminated bro in the cctv
6-3 picking up [ __ ] by the throat
that shouldn't want to
[Music]
[Music]
right i noticed the other day that he's
unblocked me on whatsapp
he wants that puss again that's why why
did you notice that as well she's like
did you go on a thing
of course she must have got the picture
for the reaper yeah she's still hung up
on it yeah she's been checking of course
daily
of course right am i an [ __ ] if i pop
back up and see if he's down to chill
again
i know it's wrong because of what he did
to my sister
but i just know the amount of hate this
guy has for me now
he's going to be a different breed and i
just want to experience it once more for
old times sake
oh my god
have you say what you need to say bro oh
my god
i feel like
honestly speaking
if i was in his shoes and you hollered
me up again
i'm 36 and you want to bang me after all
of that
because i'm gonna wanna do stuff take
[ __ ]
hey [ __ ] you bro hey [ __ ]
and i'm like
it's gonna it's gonna go down i know you
do it it's gonna go
down but i'll sling her off after that
but sex would be disgraceful shame on
you the sex would be disgraced shame on
you shame on you shame on you
as soon as i read that i messaged you
and i was like that's your type
that's your one million percent run
through
because do you know what that reminded
me of when you gave me this scenario of
yeah just busting down my door scratched
your face over my face and it just spat
in my mouth well i spat
in her mouth and she just swallowed it
and she licked her lips like
hard immediately yeah of course of
course
of course of course i don't control
these things yeah she knows to text me
i wouldn't have followed her of course i
know i know bro i know
i know shame on you bro i know she's
[ __ ] crazy she is crow i'm not i'm
not denying the fact
quick i'm 36. she's 22 she's [ __ ] of
course she's crazy
she can do 10 times better than me what
am i bringing it to the table but
he's lending you money he's lending me
money cause of course she can look
better than me
oh my god you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's ego i'm i'm 36 now i'm him now yeah
yeah yeah
his ego is like this young buck wants me
she's young and she's down i'm never
getting this opportunity ever again
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i've got
the opportunity to do what i
want consent you know
consent i have to add that in there for
parental advisory you know i didn't want
this sir
my mom said consent you know
man said just the golden goose consensus
bro
wow i can't be involved in that
situation in that scenario bro
oh god that's fine i would swallow spit
and say yes
come through i'll be so innocent are we
as soon as i bust mine out i'd oh i'd be
so ashamed
i'd be so ashamed i know you would i'll
be sorry i know you would
what the well whilst i'm home alone
actually i'm waiting for it to come
through
i'll be so sorry i'd be like you need to
you can't get here fast enough
you can't get here fast enough because
oh my god
it's bold of course
she does not know what message she's
going to get back
she does she's tearing the frame of my
diamond she's
terri she doesn't even know what's going
to happen when she gets there
you could kill her he could
have said he's come through she has no
inkling
oh my daisy she's so down to get banged
that she risk it she's risking it all
because she
knows you're going to hate [ __ ] me oh
wow
that's that's crazy man that's crazy
it's sexy but it's i would while this is
bold i would go upstairs have a wank
before i reply
yeah the wank i'll have in my head will
be off the
chain bro that's the thing i feel like
that's the reason why i'd say yes
because
um yes to [ __ ] others because we've
mentioned before that
i'm a visual like you can close your
mind and my imagination is wonderful
your imagination
i need to watch side yeah so for me to
then load up let's see like it's all the
fantasy's gone
yeah yeah yeah i can't yeah now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's why
yeah yeah for me bro
i'll read the message out of like
trouble mad
i mean i'll fap one out and then i'll
breathe another like really cool
read the message right you're off your
[ __ ] nut
what do you mean bro you need to seek
mental health
i grips your sister by a neck and dasher
on the floor
your family harassed me in my place a
bit i got sacked
you think i was broke before yeah oh god
you think i was broke before
i'm burying all the money now oh i'm
borrowing all the money
leave your card at the doorstep bro yeah
what's wrong with it imagine the [ __ ] oh
yeah of course it'd be great bro but
like i said the shame
oh yeah that will win okay when i'm done
yeah of course as soon as i've bought
someone i'll be like 36 year old man
oh man
going through that whole cycle and then
just to smash her again at the end
that's what you call rock bot i'm
basically like
yeah uh after you nut you're you're
slammed
bro and you're just like can i get any
lower than this
oh it's she's giddy
she got exactly what she wanted she's
skipping out she's hop skipping out back
to her merry old life
just to leave you to wallow in lonely
shame wow
wow and the next time if she hollers you
again you're not going to get anything
yeah yeah
because all the hate thing just done no
no no you don't even hate her anymore
because you just smashed it and it's
like oh
you hate yourself that's it that's it
oh that's a shame so what's she an
[ __ ] for wanting to do it
um i would have said no you're not an
[ __ ] you're just crazy but
now that i know no now that we've really
fed into the emotions of what it would
actually do to this mental state
you are an awesome you are an [ __ ] of
course you are an [ __ ] you're
playing on the fact of his disdain for
you to get a more intense orgasm for
yourself
that's psychopath when you actually deep
it that's what it is you're a narcissist
you're playing on his emotional state by
the
trauma that he's experienced from your
family
as a way to get a better nut for
yourself
his pain brings you pain which brings
you pleasure yeah which is
sadistic i think i think that's it
it's very sadistic yeah that actually is
twisted twisted bro
deep in it it's twisted i'm sorry you
delved into it yeah
yeah his pain will bring you pain
which will bring you pleasure wow
[Music]
yeah you've got some soul-searching
i'm concerned i'm not gonna lie we've
got you've got some
demons bro you've got some daddy issues
oh yeah she does she's got daddy issues
she does she's got that
yeah man we'll be having a good time
looking forward to it
thanks guys peace